we all say we want to be with someone
nice it sounds so plausible
tell you about this date last night what
happened it was I mean the worst you
think they're not gonna get any worse
but then they do it just doesn't make
sense I mean you're clever you're pretty
you're funny why can't you find the
right man thank you
yeah well all I'm looking for I don't
think it's too much to ask is someone
who's gonna kind funny nice had normal
but in practice it's pretty hard to deal
with niceness when it does come along so
I didn't run same person would you like
to go for a drink sometime yeah okay I
could call you about 9 o'clock after
1:00 yeah a tiny part of us might think
if they're any good why they interested
in us at the most amazing time last
night thank you love the color of your
hair if we aren't totally convinced of
our own love ability another person's
affections can be a bit unnerving when
they'd rather be with someone else is
something wrong with them they're nice
little can be so unsettling you might
even try a trick
oh hi it's me
Kitana
people who treat us like [ __ ] can seem
like they understand something profound
about life and about us yeah Norma I'm
just an office in the moment yeah before
I call Celia you were doing you wanted
to hang out next week sort of time is
good all I'll call you oh yeah no you
you call me and we'll figure it out
their assessment of us is more in line
with our assessment of ourselves we
shouldn't hold it against nice people if
they like us maybe they see something in
us we've overlooked but you the nice
ones shouldn't be naive either it's very
frightening to have to deal with
niceness it can be unfamiliar you can
freak some of us out so be ready for us
to panic and hang on in there
you
you